you
I want to see the French defense I want
to show you the that one variation where
it plays very poorly with that Queenie
to queenside castle it's not doing that
though mmm okay I feel a little more
confident though with that particular
line no I take that
okay and now what I'm gonna work on this
Bishop I'm gonna try to show that this
bishop is bad that's what I'm working
for here to reinforce my Center this is
the best spot for my night but maybe I
should make sure this night doesn't get
out of control okay I feel very
comfortable again in this position okay
it's doing kind of nothing issues I want
to trade dark square bishop x' yeah it's
not gonna allow that so easily though
huh nope but um let's stop this stuff
from happening here yeah okay let's see
if I could avoid I feel like I should
win this one I really do I really really
do
and I'm gonna do something that looks
very awkward but yeah you see look at
this it's nonsense
okay let's see what you got
Bishop h6 not afraid of that though I'm
just not afraid of this stuff my queen
is covering it my queen is clearly
covering that hang on
rook here is that gonna be annoying
maybe maybe I should play here first and
if rook B I just do this I don't have to
do this right away
let's go Queen hear me rook here yeah I
figured I figured you'd do that let's
defend stuff once I have defended
everything then let's see how tough you
are
I could queenside castle oh here comes
the big bad wolf here comes the queenie
yepper
all righty drop the knight back I want
to defend this pawn and then exchange
Queens you know what I also have to
worry about sacrifices against here with
night jumping in yeah you know what I
thought about
I thought about rook here and meeting
Queen f6 with the castles but that's
tactically flawed this pawn isn't a pin
allows a piece sack on that square I
think I need to come back here not even
allow the Queen to get into this square
let's do it hopefully there's no sack on
h5 oh man I see the end yeah Queen g7 is
gonna be a killer Oh
can I still salvage this though I mean I
don't have to take that guy and I'm not
going to just not gonna do it
I'm not gonna take but it's actually
well it's just very uncomfortable now
Queen f6 of course of course you would
do that let's defend yep
I mean here I guess I'm not giving up
that easily no way no way
you see what it's ready to do Queen here
age six Queen takes Queen pawn takes
Queen my rook is dead I have an idea
though if h6 King here they might do
that and at the end it might lose that
pawn dust miscalculate sometimes please
be safe I could get that pawn back ah
where are you going - what are you so
afraid of okay I need to take that Queen
so let me just anticipate the eventual
temple gaining move let's go here or
should I make sure I get that let me
make sure I have that Queen there let's
go here
King f6 and then here I got that Compaq
hang on hang on he's mine
okay the material is balanced the
material is officially balanced where
does my knight wanna be here to kick
this rook out of there maybe I should do
this move first then try and trap the
rook mm come on let's go let's go let's
go less than a minute here there's push
or is there because I have pressure
against this pawn now that's defended so
we're gonna be seeing that move let's
still do this though here we go I could
do takes takes Knight I don't want to
open the position up though
let's do this
get that rook out of here that rook is
what a pain man my king needs to come
over to c7 but before I do that I can't
allow this rook to enter my king is
gonna have to take a hike yeah that's
what's gonna happen let me stop that
bishop from even thinking about
attacking my knight okay it's doing
nothing it's back to doing something but
I want to make sure I get over to the
h-file yeah
less than 20 that rook is just not going
away quietly is he it's just just
doesn't want to go away
my King needs to get back over oh man
oh it's gonna play here maybe not I get
my knight into this square making some
progress here maybe I should have done
that to reinforce my Center my centers
collapsing now mmm
yeah it's super tricky super tricky now
oh maybe I could get this trade oh I
have that I'd have to worry about that
tricky Knight now let's do this with the
night here oh you know what there's
gonna be a pawn push mmm maybe I could
hold it to a draw rook takes pawn rook
here no I got to do this pawn push this
is gonna be brutal
I still hold do a drop rook takes pawn
oh that's a killer
I missed that that F for break I should
have moved my night just to make sure I
have F six to reinforce this e5 pawn
that was an interesting game
you